[Music]
jamie-lynn Sigler and her little boy
beau Kyle Dykstra enjoyed some mommy Sun
time at the launch of Hayley Duff's new
kids clothing line little moon Society
[Music]
it's been over a year since Jamie
revealed her private battle with
multiple sclerosis you've really
inspired so many people with sharing
your journey with immense how are you
feeling right now I'm feeling good thank
you
I think you know me sharing my
experiences with living with MS has
helped me tremendously as well just
because I think lifting the burden of
sort of living with this secret but also
being able now to be in touch with other
people that are living at the disease
and I don't feel so alone
I just hope to set a good example for my
son that you know living honestly and
truthfully and that no matter what
obstacles you may have in life you know
you're so deserving of opportunity and
love any plans to expand the family are
you good with oh yeah no we we love
being parents so we're definitely
talking about and hoping to expand our
family
[Music]
you